ladies and gentlemen Commission is very
satisfied that the council managed to
reach the general approach on collective
raters and we we congratulate the VINs
presidency for making this this happened
very good work done and and the
facilitation Berg was very important in
order to reach the agreement we all
remember recent scandals like dieselgate
and Cambridge analytic and other mass
sham situation like massive flight
cancellations or unfair contract terms
in Maltese agreements they all violated
consumer rights and left consumers
helpless when caught in such a situation
consumers often shy away from defending
the rights individually take it or lack
the time or money or simply don't know
who to turn to for help or how to take
action so once adopted the new rules
wills will ensure access to justice for
consumers in mass harm situation they
will also deter dishonest traders from
preaching European consumers rights so
today's agreement is an important step
in that direction and it sends a very
positive signal to the Parliament
another topic I want to raise is rather
negative Commission is dissatisfied for
the outcome of today's council meeting
on public country-by-country reporting
we regret that the council wasn't able
to find a compromise even though the
finished presidency was very helpful
providing compromise verdicts but
unfortunately we cannot get there in
this point of time this is very
important from the functioning of single
market point of view it's a matter of
fairness and once the companies are
paying taxes why not informing the other
parts of the society how much they are
paying taxes
so I hope that the process will move on
and the council managed would manage to
find a compromise or the final wording
in in foreseeable future hopefully by
the end of this presidency I stopped
here